sports teams are often bonfires of cash
yet they still change hands for billions
of dollars how can that be
[Music]
pro sports are hotter than ever we've
seen acquisitions of the nfl's denver
broncos english soccers chelsea fc and
italy's ac milan
check out this chart the 15 billion
dollars of deals completed in pro sports
by august 2022 were already more than
any full year on record
part of that's to do with it having been
easier to borrow money when interest
rates were low coupled with the soaring
value of broadcast rights but even then
how do the new owners of chelsea a team
that regularly loses more than 100
million dollars a year decide it's worth
more than three billion dollars
it's a particularly challenging question
in european soccer when you try to
decide how much a business is worth you
tend to look at how much money it's
going to make over the next few years
and work back from there if you're
confident you can predict how much a
company will make in 10 years time and
that's a high number then the company
gets a high valuation if you can only
predict two or three years out and it's
a low number the valuation is far far
lower too in soccer accurately
predicting how much money you're going
to make is an all but impossible task
get relegated to a lower division or
fail to qualify for the lucrative
champions league and you might take a
100 million dollar hit to your annual
revenue sell a star player and you might
get a one-off hundred million boost to
your revenue
just look at how annual sales have
shaped up at the italian giant juventus
over the past decade it's a veritable
roller coaster
nfl teams in stark contrast enjoy far
more stable predictable earnings the
league shares merchandising and
broadcasting revenue pretty evenly
across the league so the teams have good
visibility on how much money they're
going to receive
at the same time there's a salary cap so
they've also got a good sense of how
much money they're going to spend
that's why nfl teams get such high
valuations
soccer teams are trickier but there is a
solution of sorts it's known as the
markham multivariate model named after
this guy tom markham who developed it a
decade ago as a phd student it's a kind
of complicated equation that looks like
this
it starts by looking at the value of the
club's assets it's playing squad it's
stadium and other facilities and how
much money it's able to generate from
those assets
but it then adds in a few other
variables that help gauge how well-run
the club is and how popular it is by
looking at what percentage of the
stadium is filled in an average game you
can get a sense of how well the club is
managing to attract fans
a higher percentage means it's more
popular and perhaps better run therefore
it generates a higher valuation the
percentage wage ratio meanwhile looks at
how much of the club's income is used to
pay the playing squad a higher
percentage means the club may not be run
very efficiently so its earnings may not
be as sustainable and therefore
generates a lower valuation is this a
perfect solution no but it is a formula
that a lot of would be sports team
owners use ultimately the answer to the
question what is a sports team worth is
well whatever somebody is willing to pay
for it but in order to get to that
number you need a starting point and
that's what the model provides
[Music]